you've worked with uh veterans
um what is PTSD in that context what
what's the landscape of psychological
sufferings that
veterans soldiers go through
um
well if we're talking about combat
exposure
you're seeing
things you're not meant to see you're
seeing the worst of humanity people
harming other people it's not natural
for
um others to intend to harm us it's not
natural for us to harm others and
this dehumanization can occur that's so
troubling and disturbing that people
have a hard time living with it later or
they just feel this ongoing anger
um
it's it depends it depends on the trauma
they're exposed to it depends on you
know whether their Convoy was ambushed
by weapons that were purchased from
money that was given to this Village
from the US government
it depends on whether
um
they did something that they have a hard
time reconciling outside of War now that
they're back home in Civilization
um depends on whether they lost a lot of
um their comrades and feel that guilt of
being a Survivor and again not everybody
develops PTSD it really it's a mental
disorder it's serious we talk so much
about trauma and PTSD gets thrown around
lightly when actually it's very
difficult to meet the full criteria for
that diagnosis and many people
experience severe trauma in their lives
and only about 14 percent are likely to
actually develop PTSD it's an exception
not the norm
traumatic stress is absolutely normal
after something traumatic happens you'll
likely have nightmares you'll likely
have anxiety you'll feel depressed
because you're a human being and
something abnormal happened but PTSD is
a longer standing condition that is is
significantly impairing in a person's
life and I think we've lost that in some
of the sort of narrative in society it
just everybody has PTSD but no you can
have traumatic stress you can be
distressed you can be affected by trauma
and not have that particular diagnosis
PTSD
significantly impairs people's lives
how do veterans how do soldiers who
suffer from PTSD are close to that kind
of diagnosis begin to heal
with what's what's the path for healing
well I will hand it to the military
because I think in terms of working with
their active duty service members they
really invest heavily in mental health
the U.S Department of Defense was one of
the first to bring animal assisted
therapy into any type of treatment in
the early 1900s with uh bringing you
know farming into certain hospitals and
letting veterans help with the farms and
brush the horses and which is so
Advanced because now we have all this
research on animal assisted therapy and
um how beneficial it is and just looking
in the eyes of a dog can increase your
pain threshold and speed healing after a
cardiac arrest help people with dementia
to ambulate more freely it's incredible
stuff simple uh and the military was
ahead of the game on that and I don't
think that's changed I did my training
at a military Hospital in Hawaii tripler
Army Medical Center it was phenomenal
training and you know our psych
Department there was so much interesting
research going on we had and it was so
integrated so you might not imagine that
the military would be doing this but we
had an acupuncture Department we had a
chiropractic Department we had a yoga
section we were doing yoga sessions
there
um I mean they anything that has
evidence to support its efficacy was
being utilized and I think that's pretty
cool about our government they have a
lot of funding so I'm glad they're using
it on that the real challenge I think
comes with the large-scale need of the
veteran population
and they slipped through the cracks I
know that the dod had a campaign going
where they were doing Outreach to
anybody who served for instance in the
Vietnam War the problem is they were
trying to get all of these people
assessed for PTSD and it was great like
they were getting phone calls mail it
was sort of saying hey we know that you
served come on in or let's schedule you
an exam with a psychologist and just see
if your owed benefits the idea of it's
great the problem is that they
outsourced to this third-party company
they're paying really low rates for one
hour meeting with a vet and you don't
need to be specifically trained in
assessing PTSD
um
and so you're getting these variations
and opinions that are coming through and
I've had clients who to me who I've
worked with for years who have clear
combat related PTSD according to Gold
Standard measures according to my
knowing them and observing their
symptoms and how impaired they are and
it is clearly associated with combat the
content of their intrusive thoughts
their nightmares Etc uh and they are
having a one-hour meeting sometimes by
phone with one of these psychologists
who's been contracted by this third
party organization that's not even
enough for me to get through the first
three few symptom questions on the Caps
five assessment for PTSD but in that
hour the psychology psychologist is
saying definitively no PTSD
and it's been a travesty for some people
especially for those who need an
advocate the most it tends to happen to
my veterans who are maybe a little bit
less sophisticated in presenting or
advocating for themselves more humble
less
um you know the guys who need it deserve
it the most right they're just getting
passed over and um and it's a maze I'm
not quite sure what the solution is
though before I mean I've worked for
government agencies they're dealing it's
a massive population I love that the
Outreach is even happening and trying to
get these guys in for assessment I think
we can criticize any system
um I'm glad that system is even
happening but it still needs to be
better so I've I've got a chance to
interact with a lot of soldiers from uh
that served in Iraq and Afghanistan and
now a lot of soldiers from all different
kinds of nations in Ukraine went to the
front
there's a there's a bond between
soldiers unlike any other I don't know
if you can speak to why do you think
that is on the opposite side of PTSD
there's a there's a deep human
connection there's like a love for each
other what is that what what is that
about war and combat that creates that
kind of well you're seeing a
we've talked earlier about that
vulnerability right so
I I believe that combat I believe that
most survival situations strip away all
ego and
um
real and I mean there are a couple
different layers to this but I have not
served in war so I um I want to be
cautious here but
from what I know uh just about
psychology and also from my own
experience of survival survival type
experiences when you're with a group of
people and uh
all the ego Stripped Away Nothing Else
Matters the focus is on the here and now
and a specific Mission
um or your day-to-day
you can get really close you're very
very vulnerable and
um and also
in my experience the guys I work with
who have served there aren't a lot of
people who understand what they've been
through not only some of the Unspeakable
things they've been through in combat
but some of the things that they feel
are unspeakable about returning
especially if they are experiencing
trauma a lot of them you know some of
the things that service members with
PTSD are the most reluctant to disclose
is the feeling like they may not know if
they love their children anymore or
their wife
that they don't even know if they can
love anymore that they feel emotionally
numb
um
that they want to kill someone that they
have a whole lot of racist beliefs and
thoughts
um there are a lot of things that can be
associated with PTSD that aren't as
clear or expected and these guys
don't have many people who understand it
or they don't think they would
um but a lot of their fellow service
members do
and so I'm going back to Ukraine and um
boy nothing makes
nothing makes uh reveals The Human
Condition
in a more pure form than War
especially the kind of War you get in
that in that part of the world
especially the war in Ukraine which is a
very 20th century kind of War
um brutal